well I think actually Americans can
understand me the listener is much more
than they think I mean you know
Europeans don't believe in religion in
that sense and religion is not a big
part of European politics it's a big
part of American politics I think we've
come in the past years to try to explain
everything through Islam too much Islam
does matter but so does Christianity in
America but you cannot explain
everything in America even in the South
even among religious groups by by just a
religious explanation you definitely
cannot say well that's what the Bible
says or the Bible makes them that way
there is too much where I think in
public discussion in America a lack of a
deliberate lack of sophistication in
trying to understand and analyze the
Muslim world trying to reduce everything
into the language of religion trying to
say well you know everything is about
religion and I think that's an imbalance
that hurts us because then it's very
easy to gloss over really shoes and then
you know sort of end up in these
cultural explanations that then to all
of us appear to be unbridgeable and you
and an America and then it makes
Americans basically to throw up their
arms and say we just don't get it we
don't understand them but I think they
do I think actually that's the same
problem in the Muslim world I think
Muslims would understand Americans a lot
better if they didn't look also through
a cultural civilizational lens and they
looked at Americans and American policy
in terms of interests and aspirations
that also drives them all the time I
think you know when we talk about
dialogue it's not really about let me
understand your religion and you should
understand mine I pray five times a day
you go to church but we both believe in
the same God that's not the useful
dialogue dialogue really means trying to
understand the other sides of these
interests and behaviors in terms of how
you would have operated in a political
arena as